[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité c'est à faire
rêver tout ce qui cherche un loyer pas
trop cher 5 euros 75 c'est le prix du
mètre carré à Darney cette ville des
Vosges est la moins chère de France pour
une location reportage et explications
immobilières à suivre de Vosges
télévision dans quelques instants
un salon de coiffure dans un camion
voilà une idée innovante en faveur du
maintien des commerces dans les
territoires ruraux près de Rennes une
coiffeuse se déplace de villages en
village nous expliquera la rédaction de
TVA
c'est un savoir-faire historique et
encore bien vivant dans l'Oise et au TV
nous fera découvrir l'activité de l'une
des dernières clousteries d'Europe sur
place 2800 références sont fabriqués
tout en respectant des procédés du 19e
siècle vous verrez et puis en fin de
journal que diriez-vous d'embarquer à
bord d'une montgolfière pour un
rendez-vous en altitude en Haute-Savoie
une station accueillie est une rencontre
internationale unique en son genre des
images et un décor à couper le souffle
que nous dévoilera la chaîne 8 Mont
Blanc
maison débute donc cette édition avec
cette somme étonnante 5 euros 75
centimes c'est le prix du mètre carré
dans la ville la moins chère de France
Darney petite commune des Vosges est
ainsi la plus accessible du pays pour
une location un titre nordifique selon
les données du ministère du logement qui
focalise la tension sur cette ville
encore méconnue jusque là comme a pu le
constater la rédaction de Vosges
télévision sur place regardez
Darney un millier d'habitants à 40
minutes d'Épinal et un peu plus d'une
heure de Nancy une commune qui vient de
faire parler d'elle à l'échelle
nationale d'après les données publiées
fin décembre par le ministère du
Logement c'est ici que l'on trouve les
loyers les moins chers de France depuis
cette annonce les coups de fil se sont
multipliés en mairie impressionnant de
toute la France voir la Guadeloupe
Guadeloupe Lot-et-Garonne dans le Nord
la Savoie enfin tout le monde voulait
changer pour les venir prendre l'air à
Darney le prix moyen au mètre carré est
de 5 euros 75 exemples avec cet
appartement de 80 mètres carrés
habitables dont le loyer mensuel et de
345 euros toutes charges comprises des
prix qui se retrouvent d'ailleurs sur
tout le canton à cela une explication
essentiellement d'ordre économique selon
ce professionnel de l'immobilier d'Arnay
montureux-sur-saône la marche sont des
secteurs où il n'y a pas d'emploi donc
pas d'emploi donc vieillissement massif
de la population d'armée a perdu son
collège par exemple
donc à partir de là on a très peu de
candidats d'après nos critères solvables
et si l'on parle cette fois de vente la
dernière un pavillon en bon état on va
tourner autour des 1000 euros le mètre
carré par contre la majeure partie des
biens qu'on va rencontrer sont des biens
à rénover et pourtant toujours en
matière de biens avant de la
municipalité d'arnéenne sans que le vent
pourrait tourner dans la bonne direction
sur Darney sur la marche un petit peu et
on a beaucoup de d'achat de maison et la
particularité de la des Vosges côté
sud-ouest de communes qui est la
compétence scolaire malgré la perte de
600 élèves par an au niveau du
département nous avons la chance nous
d'avoir d'être en augmentation cette
année d'élèves donc ce qui veut dire que
si élève et des parents il y a des
familles qui arrivent qui s'installent
elles restent que les acheteurs
potentiels ou propriétaires actuels qui
souhaiteraient mettre leurs biens à la
location devront au préalable réaliser
des travaux de mise en conformité
énergétique ce qui devrait mécaniquement
faire baisser les prix de l'immobilier à
Darney comme ailleurs
voilà et là où les prix de l'immobilier
sont accessibles et les commerces
parfois rares des initiatives se
développent pour répondre aux besoins
des populations dans la région rennaise
un salon de coiffure original vous allez
le voir proposer ses services depuis
quelques années
itinérant le salon de Cindy bienfaits
passent de ville à janvillage pour
couper et brosser les mèches rebelles
une idée aussi utile que sociale un
sujet de la chaîne TVA à Rennes
le mercredi à Boistrudan c'est le
bonjour pour aller chez le coiffeur
depuis 4 ans Cindy bienfaits s'installe
avec son camion aménagé en salon sur la
place de la mairie
plutôt que de louer un local dans le
village cette jeune entrepreneuse a
choisi l'itinérance elle se déplace sur
neuf communes rurales et le salon ne
désemplit pas il y a des commerces qui
ne peuvent pas tenir à longueur de temps
donc l'itinérance permet en fait de
faire ce compromis entre amener un
service mais de ne pas être là tout le
temps depuis la rentrée Cindy a même
embauché une coiffeuse à mi-temps pour
la soulager et lui permettre de se
pencher sur son projet de deuxième salon
Mobile Alexandre Vallès fondateur de mon
petit camion l'accompagne dans ses
démarches cette association vise à
dynamiser les communes rurales grâce
notamment au commerce et inhérents quand
on croise ses besoins de faire du lien
et de travailler sur l'économie locale
on trouve on peut trouver des ressources
pour booster un peu les communes rurales
sachant que ça le vend le poulpe en plus
il y a un besoin je pense un besoin de
proximité un besoin de se dire on n'est
pas oublié
dans le monde rural et je vienne ici
parce qu'effectivement
l'immobilier est moins cher ou alors un
besoin de campagne mais c'est de se dire
tiens on s'occupe de nous un petit peu
ici le salon itinérant porte bien son
nom le temps d'une écoute au delà du
côté pratique et attractif ce service
c'est aussi un vecteur de lien social
tout le monde se connaît donc forcément
il y a ce plaisir de se croiser de
d'avoir un petit mot gentil
et le samedi Cindy pousse l'itinérance
jusqu'au bout avec un service à domicile
pour soutenir le commerce de proximité
découvrant cette autre projet mise en
place dans l'Aube une boutique en
libre-service avec des produits 100%
locaux ce magasin que vous découvrez sur
ces quelques images de la rédaction de
Canal 32 propose plus de 150 produits à
la vente à emporter une idée
intéressante pour les habitants pressés
mais néanmoins désireux de bien
s'alimenter écouter à ce propos les
explications de la gérante de la
boutique on a tous des vies
professionnelles et personnelles bien
remplies et j'étais la première à un peu
galérer pour bien manger si je puis dire
à courir à gauche et à droite pour bien
s'approvisionner et on a la chance parce
qu'on habite à la campagne mais je me
suis dit que les gens qui habitent au
centre-ville n'avaient pas cette chance
là si on veut manger j'ai envie de dire
sur le pouce mais bien manger c'est
compliqué parce que ces soirs
restaurants n'en a pas forcément le
temps au budget ou alors après c'est du
c'est on mange rapidement mais c'est pas
forcément un sandwich enfin c'est pas
forcément adapté moi aujourd'hui on
propose des plats traiteurs à 7,50 donc
c'est il y a juste à mettre au
micro-onde c'est plutôt sympa quand on
est au bureau et qu'on veut bien manger
un plat chaud quoi
et si bien se nourrir est important bien
se soigner est évidemment vital
malheureusement vous le savez le manque
de médecins et de plus en plus criant
par tout en France exemple une nouvelle
fois dans la Sarthe ou la dernière
généralistes d'une commune est partie à
la retraite au mois de décembre sans
remplaçant les patients se retrouvent
désormais sur le carreau certains ont
décidé de réagir et souhaite monter un
collectif précision et reportage dans
Zoo Maubert pour LMTv Sarthe
le SOS s'affiche depuis trois ans à
l'entrée de la commune et pourtant
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun médecin
à ivrer l'évêque la dernière généraliste
est partie à la retraite fin 2022 cet
habitant a été l'un de ses patients
pendant 35 ans il se retrouve désormais
sans médecin et un quai des personnes
qui habitent Yves vont faire des
kilomètres pour se soigner c'est pas le
but
on doit avoir un médecin tout proche les
personnes qui ont un certain âge qui ont
pas de moyens pour se déplacer comment
vont-ils faire c'est vraiment écrit du
coeur je ne parle pas uniquement disons
pour moi pour moi mais c'est surtout
pour l'ensemble des habitants d'ivrés
qui n'ont plus de médecins il va falloir
trouver une solution une solution oui
mais laquelle Raymond tente de fédérer
les habitants autour d'un collectif la
municipalité elle tente d'attirer sans
succès elle a même rénové cet ancien
bureau de poste en pôle santé ici vous
avez toujours deux infirmières nous
avons dedans deux cabinets médicaux qui
sont vides voilà et un logement à
l'étage au-dessus du cabinet médical qui
pourrait intéresser les médecins la
ville ne manque pas non plus de
spécialistes dentiste ostéopathes
podologue mais selon les lus le frein
est ailleurs on n'est pas prioritaire
pour avoir des LED à l'installation au
médecin parce qu'on est associé à
couleurs chargé savignier qui ont eux
ont beaucoup de médecins et qui peuvent
qui pourraient accueillir nos patients
mais dans les fêtes non il n'accueille
pas les patients des autres communes on
a tendance les habitants ont prévu de se
réunir la semaine prochaine avant une
réunion publique le 6 mars même si
chacun sait qu'il n'y aura probablement
pas de miracle
voilà restons dans la Sarthe dans ce
journal avec ces images de la venue dans
la ville du Mans de Brigitte Macron et
de Didier Deschamps pour l'opération
Pièces Jaunes la première dame et le
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France de
football ont visité la Maison des
Adolescents sur place ainsi très mauvais
grâce à la collecte annuelle en tout
depuis le lancement des pièces jaunes en
1989 ce sont près de 10000 projets qui
ont pu être financés pour améliorer la
vie des enfants hospitalisés exemple
dans la Loire avec ce reportage de TL7
regardez
ces petites chambres doubles a été
financée en partie par l'opération pièce
jaune en 2019 au total la maison de
Jonathan a pu s'offrir 6 chambres et 12
lits supplémentaires ici on accompagne
des proches hospitalisées à
Saint-Etienne mais parfois les séjours
peuvent être longs alors entre résidant
on crée des liens on oublie le quotidien
et on partage son histoire on n'a pas
tous la même histoire mais tous ceux qui
sont présents dans la maison de Jonathan
ont tous des problèmes liés au CHU en
général et du coup on se lit bien sûr
avec d'autres personnes les 1000 m² de
la maison de Jonathan s'élève à quelque
part du CHU de Saint-Étienne les
chambres équipées chacune de salles de
bain et les pièces communes permettent
de se sentir comme à la maison la maison
de Jonathan parce que finalement on a
tout et je veux dire
on a une à la cuisine on a le salon
c'est quand même c'est pas notre maison
mais c'est un peu une maison en
secondaire la maison de Jonathan a
ouvert ses portes en 2002 elle s'est
vite avéré indispensable le CHU de
Saint-Étienne enregistre de nombreuses
naissance prématurée les familles ont
souvent besoin de se rapprocher ça
touche toujours par rapport aux enfants
déjà mais bon il y a quand même un gros
service de réanéonat sur le CHU
Saint-Étienne qui dirait à neona dit
grand prématurés dit petit bébé qui ont
besoin de leurs parents à côté et les
parents ne peuvent pas vivre au CHU avec
les tarifs varie de 8 à 35 euros en
fonction des revenus cela comprend
évidemment la nuit mais aussi le petit
déjeuner jusqu'au 4 février prochain le
don est possible en ligne par SMS par
chèque ou dans les très célèbres
tirelire en carton
voilà c'était il y a 6 mois tout juste
en plein cœur de l'été plus de 30 000
hectares de forêts par tête en fumée en
Gironde des incendies records non sans
conséquence bien sûr sur la faune et sur
la flore locale et alors qu'une
catastrophe était redoutée pour la
biodiversité les animaux du mois les
plus gros semblent déjà de retour sur
les zones sinistres une bonne nouvelle
dévoilée grâce à des opérations de
référencement nocturnes la chaîne TV7 la
chaîne du groupe Sud-Ouest a pu suivre
l'une de ses sorties de nuit regardez
le gyrophare et les feux allumés cette
voiture de la fédération de chasse de
Gironde arpente les routes abordant les
lisières de forêt touchées par les
incendies l'été dernier ce soir là c'est
la zone située entre Belin-Béliet et
Hostens sont suggironde qui est scrutés
à bassalur et de nuit ces techniciens
synégétiques procèdent au comptage des
animaux qui peuvent observer grâce à une
caméra thermique
un brocard on va les bois qui n'est pas
des oreilles les données récoltées en
fonction du nombre d'animaux des
différentes espèces observées sont
notifiées sur une carte numérique depuis
la fin des incendies se comptage a lieu
une fois par semaine la fédération de
chasse de la Gironde a identifié trois
circuits différents de 25 km chacun à la
teste un autre à Landiras le dernier à
Belin-Béliet un tour de rôle ils sont
empruntés par ces techniciens dans le
sens aller et retour chaque semaine ils
ont vu petit à petit la nature
reprendront ses droits
donc par exemple de chevreuils au départ
sur les circuits voyons on en voyait
vraiment peu alors que maintenant
ressemble à peu près autour des 15 20
individus par sortie donc on arrive à
peu près au même niveau que ce qu'on
voyait un petit peu avant les incendies
sangliers chevreuil bichez France ont
donc incontestablement de retour si l'on
en croit ces techniciens et la présence
de certains prédateurs comme le renard
par exemple ici sur cette image prouve
que même les petits animaux commencent
eux aussi à revenir ce retour est
toutefois plus long il est aussi moins
évident établir que pour les grands
animaux
hérissons Mulot et autres serpents ont
certainement payé le plus lourd tribu
dans ces incendies
voilà ici il avait reprend quelques peu
ses droits dans nos forêts c'est grâce
bien entendu au travail dès
sapeurs-pompiers les soldats du feu
comme on les appelle qui se forment tout
au long de l'année dans le Finistère
d'ailleurs les pompiers peuvent
désormais s'entraîner sur une plateforme
de réalité virtuelle objectif formé plus
simplement mais tout aussi efficacement
reportage bien réel celui-là des Noura
le nôtres pour TBO la chaîne du groupe
Le Télégramme en Bretagne
Régis tu seras le chef du groupe
incendie un incendié déclaré dans un
appartement mais c'est depuis cet
ordinateur que les pompiers régleront la
situation pour former les
sapeurs-pompiers le 10 à installer une
plateforme de réalité virtuelle qui
simule des interventions un moyen
d'entraîner les futurs recrues sans
mobiliser de dispositifs trop importants
pour nous c'est que ça nous permet de
simuler des interventions sans avoir
tout l'infrastructure humaine et
logistique de le nombre de véhicules
nécessaires pour pouvoir faire ce type
de simulation donc c'est très très
intéressant pour nous de pouvoir
travailler plusieurs fois répéter c'est
un temps ces interventions deuxième
objectif et donc tu es victime tu les
envoies a eu au lieu de rassemblement
des impliqués après la simulation chaque
étape de l'intervention est décryptée
jusqu'à cette participant peuvent se
connecter simultanément sur la
plateforme alors la virtualité est-elle
aussi formatrice qu'une situation réelle
pour le 10 il n'y a pas de doute des
études démontent que le
en terme d'apprentissage le cerveau ne
fait pas beaucoup de différence entre
une situation vécue en réel et une
situation en réalité virtuelle 20
session de formation sont organisées en
2023 en tout 150 agents seront formés
cette année via la plateforme de réalité
virtuelle
la réalité virtuelle qui est aussi et
surtout un moyen moderne de se divertir
la preuve avec le développement en
France des salles de eSport sur place
les joueurs équipés d'un casque d'une
arme et d'un ordinateur s'affrontent
dans des arènes une bataille aussi
virtuelle que réelle mais surtout
physique comme a pu le constater Mirco
petchi dans le dernier espace du genre
inauguré regardez son reportage réalisé
pour la rédaction de télégramme
[Musique]
on est plus proche d'une aventure de
d'un laser game en termes de sensation
de déplacement mais avec ce côté eSport
et réalité virtuelle avec le casque quoi
l'objectif est de développer l’esport à
Grenoble plusieurs villes en France ont
déjà leur propre bataillon la salle
dispose aussi d'un espace de streaming
ou seront commentés les prochains
tournois pour le moment on est au
prémicin les premières timisport sont en
train de faire leurs entraînements
derrière nous et on espère pouvoir
organiser le premier tournoi de Grenoble
sur la fin février la salle est ouverte
tous les jours de 16 heures à minuit et
le week-end de 10 heures à minuit
comptez 20 euros pour la partie de 40
minutes de quoi s'entraîner pourquoi pas
vaincre les champions lors de la Coupe
de France qui se jouera à Paris en
novembre 2023
du sport elle en pratique tous les jours
du fait de son activité professionnelle
Pauline Pradier vient d'être élu Miss
agricole 2023 cette vigneronne a été
choisie sur les réseaux sociaux parmi
plus d'une centaine de candidates la
jeune femme de 31 ans représentera ainsi
le monde agricole durant toute l'année
premier rendez-vous le mois prochain à
Paris pour le Salon de l'Agriculture
rencontre pour leur sur ces terres du
Gard avec Laurie charmella journaliste
polar rédaction de vie Occitanie
pas question de parader avec son écharpe
quelques jours après son élection retour
dans les vignes pour Pauline Pradier
c'est la saison de la taille de la vigne
des tâches de son métier qu'elle aime
partager sur les réseaux sociaux avec
ces 3000 followers une vision moderne
d'une profession parfois éloignée des
nouvelles technologies c'est d'ailleurs
sur les réseaux sociaux que la jeune
gardoise s'est fait élire Miss France
agricole face à 129 concurrentes
j'aimerais véhiculer une image positive
de l'agriculture de montrer qu'on peut
être des femmes et totalement
polyvalente sur une exploitation
agricole et je trouve ça vraiment très
intéressant de faire partager notre
passion et notre métier à travers les
réseaux sociaux parce que les gens ils
peuvent vraiment se rendre compte à quel
point on s'implique tous les jours dans
notre métier montrer notre travail à 31
ans Pauline Prady incarne cette image
contemporaine de l'agriculture depuis
qu'elle a repris le domaine familial en
2014 elle a créé quatre cuvées qu'elle
vinifie dans ses cuvées dans ses amps et
développe sa clientèle sur les réseaux
sociaux
cette passion du métier c'est son père
Michel qui lui a transmise elle va
pouvoir mettre en avant le monde
agricole des jeunes qui aujourd'hui est
en plein changement de l'agriculture
évolue énormément et c'est vrai que tous
ces jeunes qui sont là et qui méritent
que l'on s'intéresse à eux soit
représenté par une fille c'est
formidable Pauline traduire recevra son
écharpe de Miss France agricole en
février au Salon de l'Agriculture à
Paris un meurtre à l'Opéra cette annonce
de vous inquiétez pas n'a rien
d'officiel c'était l'intrigue d'inclus
et d'eau géants organisé il y a quelques
jours au sein de l'Opéra de Limoges pour
l'occasion une soixantaine de détectives
amateurs à mener l'enquête pour
découvrir le responsable du meurtre d'un
chanteur lyrique une opération menée
dans un décor éblouissant reportage de
Benjamin Delmas pour cette à Limoges
c'est le début du énigme qui a assassiné
le chanteur lyrique du prochain opéra
jouait à Limoges la Dame Blanche une
enquête menée par une soixantaine de
détectives amateurs s'ouvre alors le
tout orchestré par 2 mètres du polar
Limousin Frank Linol et Joël Nivard
tout à fait extraordinaire insolite nous
sommes à l'Opéra Théâtre de Limoges pour
organiser un Cluedo qu'on a amélioré un
peu le concept parce que on travaille
avec des comédiens si comédiens et
comédiennes qui jouent le rôle de témoin
de témoin suspect et parmi eux il y a le
ou la coupable et donc les joueurs sont
vraiment très intéressés d'aller
interroger finalement d'aller interroger
c'était avec l'Opéra Théâtre entier
comme plateau de jeu les enquêteurs en
herbe en deux heures pour démêler le
vrai du faux au gré de leurs entretiens
avec les 6 suspects
avec vous la victime est partie avec les
témoins suspects sont interprétés par
des comédiens de la compagnie de théâtre
asfodel on aime beaucoup ça parce que
c'est assez amusant et puis il y a tout
un côté d'improvisation que moi j'aime
bien en tout cas une enquête sur scène
mais aussi dans ses coulisses l'occasion
de jeter un autre regard sur cette
institution les derniers enquêteurs
rendent leur copie franklinol lève le
voile sur le mystère du meurtre de
l'Opéra c'est lui le coupable tous les
enquêteurs ont gagné ils pourront
assister à la représentation de la Dame
Blanche à la fin du mois
des coulisses de l'opéra à celle d'une
usine historique dans cette édition
prenons désormais la direction de l'Oise
ou tourne encore les machines de l'une
des dernières clouteries d'Europe la
clouterie rivière c'est son nom fabrique
depuis 135 ans tout type de clous pour
de nombreuses industries aujourd'hui
c'est sur les machines de l'époque
qu'une vingtaine de salariés préservent
ce savoir-faire très atypique découverte
de Jérémy Houron pour louer au TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord
on pourrait croire à des machines à
remonter le temps voici l'une des
dernières clouteries d'Europe encore
dans son jus c'est ici que sont
fabriqués ce Mans clouze et pointe de
toute taille sur des mécaniques
centenaires et bien huilés comme cette
machine dédiée à la fabrication de clous
forgées si on a une bobine de fil qui
est amené par la nage
grâce à quatre pressions qui sont à
l'intérieur avec deux couteaux qui
viennent couper les coups et grâce à la
perche la perche on vient faire une tête
un savoir-faire vieux de 130 ans et oui
l'usine créée en 1888 par Théodore
rivière n'a jamais cessé son activité
c'est la date de 1908 et elle tourne
encore comme une horloge si bien qu'au
fil du temps les 325 machines sont
devenues collègues c'est un ancien
ouvrier qui travaillait ici et médio qui
les a personnalisés qui leur a donné un
prénom de façon à pouvoir mieux les
reconnaître et les humaniser un petit
peu l'usine fabrique des clous pour tout
charpente batelleries tapisserie 2800
références et un cahier des charges
draconien el Albanie est pointé sa
machine est dédiée à la maroquinerie de
luxe sa mécanique tient de l'horlogerie
c'est ça rentre pas sur cette plaque
c'est pas bon on va jeter client évoque
que ça passe ici comme ça le fait il
reste un diamètre ronde chaque clou il y
a une longueur 15 10 7 6 aujourd'hui une
vingtaine de salariés préserve les
secrets de fabrication autant que
l'histoire de leur clôterie une usine
témoin de la grandeur de l'ère
industrielle et labellisé Entreprise du
Patrimoine Vivant
voilà prenons un peu de hauteur pour
terminer ce journal avec un rendez-vous
et pousse tout flanc consacré au vol en
altitude de montgolfière
organisé chaque année dans la station du
Pras sur Arly l'événement propose vous
allez le voir un balai aérien somptueux
dans un décor enneigé exceptionnel de
très belles images et un sujet de
lucaruc pour la chaîne 8 Mont-Blanc
regardez
[Musique]
prendre de la hauteur pour profiter d'un
panorama à couper le souffle voici la
clé du succès des montgolfia de
Praz-sur-Arly depuis maintenant 32
éditions
[Musique]
cet événement unique en France réunis
chaque début d'année plusieurs pilotes
pour effectuer des vols au-dessus du Val
d'Arly à mi-chemin entre les massifs du
Mont-Blanc du Beaufortain et des Aravis
que ce soit de la vue ou même les gens
les gens sont super gentils ils sont
toujours très accueillants les passagers
qu'on fait voler sont tout le temps
heureux de voir aussi au-dessus de je
suis désolé et ça ça permet nous on
connaît pas forcément
tous les endroits et comme ça les gens
nous disent ah là-bas c'est le Mont
Blanc le Pic du Midi et cetera donc
c'est ça qui est chouette
en montagne et qui plus est en hiver et
conditions atmosphériques sont très
changeantes c'est particularités font du
site de bras sur Arly a lieu
d'entraînement idéal pour les pilotes
les moins expérimentés on essaie de
d'associer un pilote qui a de
l'expérience en montagne avec un pilote
qui en a pas on peut de manière à le
faire évoluer dans ce contexte de
montagne avec une aérologie très
particulière et puis en montgolfière il
y a jamais de voile d'identique donc à
chaque fois c'est c'est une c'est un
nouveau panorama c'est c'est des
conditions différentes c'est ce qui en
fait la particularité et donc on se
lâche jamais grâce à son emplacement
exceptionnel rassure Harley est donc
définitivement le lieu de référence
d'aérostation de montagne en France
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi le grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]